es un paso hacia la legalización de las
plantaciones de Cannabis en Brasil para
uso medicinal farmacéutico e Industrial
el tribunal superior de justicia aceptó
tomar el caso tras que los esfuerzos
para su legalización en el congreso se
estancaran en los últimos años
aceptamos delimitar la cuestión de
derecho controvertida Definir la
posibilidad de concesión de una
autorización sanitaria para la
importación y el cultivo de variedades
de cannabis para usos exclusivamente
medicinales farmacéuticos o industriales
y es que en Brasil si un paciente quiere
usar Cannabis medicinal tiene que
recurrir a productos importados más
caros que si se produjeran nacionalmente
y son varias las dolencias para las que
se suele recetar autismo Severo
epilepsia o esclerosis múltiple además
de estrés o ansiedad cuya eficacia en
estos casos ha sido reconocida por la
OMS de hecho en la región son varios los
países que ya han legalizado su uso
medicinal como Uruguay Paraguay
Argentina Colombia o Perú
tiene una relevancia práctica económica
política y social muy grande por reducir
el costo de medicamentos ampliamente
utilizados por la sociedad o por la
posibilidad de introducir una nueva
industria en Brasil
de ser favorable la sentencia del
tribunal superior que se espera para el
próximo año podría convertir al
organismo judicial en pionero en la
materia como ya hizo cuando ya no el
camino para legalizar el matrimonio
entre personas del mismo sexo en 2011